et que chacun vienne ici faire une
petite danse à chaque fois que le
présente à l'éventuelle alors j'aimerais
qu'on met la musique
la première musique qui me vient quand
je le vois c'est point soleil point
soleil
jordan grand soir et une hanche comme ça
à mes yeux c'est badens et j'arrive vous
désigner le meilleur danseur chez lui le
meilleur danseur de meilleur danseur
fera une danse
je viens de trouver cette séquence du
foirail dedans c'est quelqu'un du public
d'accord vous n'avez pas capté 6 rires
je danse pas très bien mais il ya une
très forte sensualité animale qui se
dégage
bah oui il n'ya pas que l'ascension n'y
a pas que la somme ira dîner gala
ta musique alors choisissez une musique
je sais pas par exemple à nous sortir un
truc
phil anderson ouais benjamin biolay
courbe est bien dorée paris spéciaux t
il à la nation franchement non médecin
sébastien buemi le majeur de pas
d'oxydation non non
eh bien
mais bon
merci
maire de taponnat une chanson parfaite
santé très bon a plus envie d'aller dans
mon style que dans une bibliothèque
je sais que ça va partir en cacahuète de
poche flambeau calmez vous alors
j'aimerais qu'on demande maintenant à
ludivine resterait alors font
normalement c'est normalement on avait
tous les clichés la dzeko sur la danse
est au maximum star bonsoir hanoune a
enchanté les top models
on va travailler ensemble j'espère me un
très cher et c'est pourquoi je choisis
vas-y tu vois j'avais déjà entendu zouk
machine donc locaux
à
et
m
c'est plus que réciproque
vous le savez aussi qui compte c'est pas
que j'aime bien c'est qu'il chopra et
ludivine je peux me permettre
alors aucune chance 2 oui il y en a eu
deux cas aucunement kalla qui n'aura pas
ce qu'on peut dire des dos des choses
moi je suis déjà voilà vers quoi
excuse moi vous êtes invités qui à dîner
ce soir ludivine moi alors
la vérité est basé à damas rigoler
j'aime bien avant que le mec qui
t'habite adina matters et qui s'est pris
cinq plombs a branché on va dire toute
la vérité
papa de l'internaute ou tout dit la
griso invite à dîner absolument cyril il
n'était pas un acteur et elle va dit ce
n'est pas exorbitant dîner arrive à être
doublement attendez attendez deux
minutes qu'elle dit est ce que je vous
invite à dîner oui je m'y risquerai sur
rim n'a pas mis des dîners oui ça va
c'est normal vous et moi ce que vous
histoire m'avait dit j'ai un truc demain
à lyon ah oui c'est vrai j'ai apprécié
je passe à autre chose
je vous invite à dîner jamais à oops
alors je vous vois vous mangez seulement
évolué j'habitais toute l'équipe ce soir
en fait c'était la dernière arme un toit
commun non plus celui-ci vous êtes
invités à manger très prenante car le
projet proprement il est important de
matching est ni bonne ni loi et l'ordre
attention que tu choisis comme ici un
truc en plus vintage bent hamer
d'héroïne dans le bac s claire seven
géographie lugano le bac vous avez une
chorégraphie d'où est ce que le seven
d'accord oui là bas qu il faut le
trouver ça vole très haut pour la vérité
sur le connaissent tellement un garçon
sympa
ouais
je
voilà
y a des choses à dire à personne et il
en a même perdu une boucle d'oreille ont
cédé leur boîte avec des années j'étais
bouche bée ce n'est pas un truc bien en
fait
non mais tout ce que je vous connais
depuis quelques temps normalement bien
c'est moi et la rigueur c'est le maître
mot
quoi la rigueur c'est le maître mot
d'accord va respecter c'est qu'il est
super bon hommage il est bon dans ce cas
quand médias que les nus en fait
alors là alors je vous annonce tout de
suite a tout de suite fait des clignoter
le moringa il va mettre la bouche en
abord comme d'habitude on connaît par
coeur voilà il va ou sur une aventure
l'arrière en faune et en missionnaire ça
va alors là on n'avait pas la dernière
passe et votre ces partis bataille
voilà
carragher
l'allemand
allez
ces paris aux forêts réthoré ludivine
lama d'écouter l'avis général c'est même
franchement alors vous déjà c'est vrai
que franchement vous dégoûter les gens
on va alors maintenant on connaît toutes
les convois normalement la gâteau preuve
en fait elle a appelé vite c'est vrai je
serre les empaler minaude je vais leur
mariage le soir et pendant ces quelques
années plus que se joue on va faire un
petit à petit des médias sur quoi bah
c'est ce que vous voulez sur shakira à
canon pour vous remettre chaque héros
j'en ai vu 50 des comme ça en bois de sa
minauder ça fait genre non non c est
plus facile à ramener cette a3 que c'est
facile mais non jean michel vous avez
essayé mais non mais ça je connais trés
jolie mia irrattrapable à la trappe dès
qu'on dit m les syllabes bibi n'a pas
brillé coupé est brûlante en même temps
froid des boulons tombaient ouais en
fait elle c'est un pyrénéen il faut la
laisser là
non mais je danse très mal c'est vrai
alors je m'engage y devenir comme ça on
se sera fait est ce que dans ses rangs
reggaeton avec ludivine mais c'est rien
fait
mais
m
il est l'heure de rentrer je ne me rends
compte tous les soirs les gens qui
dansent le régatons bois de boulogne mer
à gafsa même chose alors quand il ya un
truc dans l'émission vous voulez
regarder comme ça
à dix minutes d'émission ça sent pas du
tout se prend pour le sniper de les
niches aussi les bombes alors bon c'est
un mot mais bon c'est quoi quand vous
produire une émission produite sur la
prochaine visite vous allez prendre mais
ce n'est pas grave
ah oui parce que vous êtes un ami a
passé tous nos demandes et je vous
remettre votre micro suis obligé de tout
faire
ah bon tu fais quelque chose tient à
réagir l'attendant cannois du toute
première fois sur le le refrain de
première fois joe dassin j'aime
tellement
la danse a fait ma carrière moi ya celle
d'acheter 9,9 et y est à bernard bernard
baudin fitch est un petit peu a fallu
que l'entente qui dormira ça on devra
aller vers l'emv où il sort en tant que
t'es pas les emboîtements autour de ce
que tu sais faire
bel étudiant musique
je
c
j'aime bien parce que tu es bon donc
c'est une donne un petit conseil je
viens de prendre ce petit mouvement là
comme ça quand on est dans le métro
oui
bien que c'est vrai si vous regardez son
équipe et sa chronique moi j'avais 15
ans je prenais les l'équipe de jonas
parker dû commencer c'est pas la danse
c'est l'émotion quand je suis près de
vous on aimerait faire une émission que
de danse ouais ouais mais où la prime
bah vous l'avouer c'est vrai que sans
rigoler c'est vrai un bail on
appellerait ça danse avec terre bmp idée
de prime
merci pour nous reste une bombe alors
sur quoi voulez danser un van
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous mettre
quelque chose de la guerre ne sont
jamais allés quoi en europe italie n'a
pas vous avez pas autre chose blain rock
rock l'héroïne avec qui des beaux-arts
je réserve a été la meilleure pour moi
oui on ne reçoit que le pacemaker n'a
plus de piles ça y est j'ai adoré ouais
bien sûr elle leur assène dans le rock
mais sans qu'on soit tous les deux
tailles même maladie oui beaucoup
c'est vrai tu peux te faire mal mais
t'inquiète pas mais là maintenant trois
jours au lit et vachement lait je suis
rien bah oui bah je fais 49 kg ouais
c'est fou tu crois que j'en sais combien
j'ai rien dit mais non de brad était
magnifique
vraiment je le dis et le redis dans un
délit prescrit
oui excusez moi savons où vous êtes dans
votre délire je suis totalement revenue
la tâche qu'est ce que tu veux ce que
vous voulez théo je te fais confiance si
tu te démerdes
m
genève
on aimerait ça
alors vous voyez vous et on sera dans
l'instant qui a été élu meilleur lanceur
de tpm p7 leurs danseurs alors en
dixième position des meilleurs danseurs
ça a été aussi été gilles labbé normal
9e
merci jean michel normal ans seulement
agathe normal 7e bernard normal 6e
ludivine à gpat honda mieux pour lui dit
ah ouais inquiète mme géraldine et oui
kelly 3e mathieu attendez attendez reste
qui le point bas c'est ma famille ah la
vache c'est donc maxime
les voici